i have a copy of the full report
234 pages of devastating analysis of
what was going on at this trust for more
than two decades and within this report
there are testimonies from staff members
who talk about how they felt that they
should always avoid doing caesareans how
the trust was proud of its low rate of
caesarean sections and indeed donna
ockendon
in some other comments that she's given
on publication of this report has said
that in some cases uh where a caesarean
wasn't given um if if the trust had
indeed intervened had indeed
given a mother a cesarean section babies
could have lived so this is one of the
causes of some of these deaths at the
trust but there were
multiple failings as donna ockendon has
been outlining this was a trust that
failed over many years to learn from
mistakes they failed to properly risk
assess mothers they failed to listen to
the concerns of mothers
and then when babies died they would
blame the mothers for their own baby's
deaths donna ockendon said that this
failure in care carried on for a
prolonged period of time she talked
about staff having told her that they
felt that they could not
speak up within the trust that they
tried to raise concerns but that they
were simply unable to staff who would
cry on shift because of what was going
on
in this trust but we know from her
report that initially when she was asked
to investigate back in 2017 there were
23 cases highlighted as being of concern
now over the years since she's been
investigating so many families contacted
her that in fact the testimonies of 1486
families went into this report and she's
concluded from the cases that she looked
at
210 deaths could have been avoided that
includes 201 deaths of babies
131 stillbirths could have been avoided
70 neonatal deaths could have been
avoided and also the deaths of nine
mothers could have been avoided if only
better care had been provided at this
trust the report also details how 94 uh
babies are now living with long-term
brain damage or cerebral palsy as a
result
of the failures in care at this trust
and
don ochonden said that her report
primarily looks at the period between
the year 2000 and 2019 but she said
she's deeply concerned that her team are
still being contacted by families who
are receiving poor care now
babies still dying
up until very recently at this trust
this is not
something that is in the past she said
she's concerned about what is still
going on and she has set out a whole
series of things that both this trust
and maternity units right across the
country need to do
to improve safety it includes better
monitoring of babies it includes more
wardrobes by doctors it includes
listening when things go wrong learning
when things go wrong now we have had
some reaction to this report from the
health secretary sajid javid and i'll
read you his response now he says donna
ockendon's report
paints a tragic and harrowing picture of
repeated failures and care over two
decades and i am deeply sorry to all the
families who've suffered so greatly
since the initial report was published
in 2020 we've taken steps to invest in
maternity services and grow the
workforce and we'll make the changes
that are needed so that no families have
to go through this pain again i would
like to thank donna ocondon and her
whole team for their work throughout
this long and distressing inquiry
as well as all the families who came
forward to tell their stories
donna ockendon was at pains to thank
those families it is only due to them
really having to shout to be heard that
we know about what was going on at this
trust because over many years there were
attempts made within the trust to
silence those families but they refused
to believe that their babies had to die
and now we know the true extent of what
was going on at this trust